-As the coronavirus outbreak
spikes for a third time,
nearing new records
in daily cases,
the president has decided on
a closing message
for the last two weeks
of the election --
whine about having to campaign
in swing states
and attack "60 Minutes"
correspondent Lesley Stahl.
For more on this, it's time for
"A Closer Look."
♪♪
Look, I know this might be
a little judgmental,
but I'm starting to think that,
maybe, just maybe,
Donald Trump is not exactly
a political mastermind.
For example, he basically tried
to make his whole campaign
about Joe Biden's
record on China.
And then it turned out,
Trump is the one who has
a secret bank account in China.
Soon, we're going to find a
photo of Trump burning down
a Target wearing a shirt that
says "I'm an anarchist!"
In fairness, if Trump
didn't want "The Times"
to find out about this,
he probably shouldn't have left
that folder on
his desktop labeled
"Not a secret Chinese
bank account."
The account was secret.
Although, knowing Trump,
there's a good chance
he would have just blurted it
out at some point anyway.
"Mr. President, do you need some
cash for the church service?"
"Yeah, just take it out of
the secret
Chinese bank account!"
And then, last night,
Trump was in Erie, Pennsylvania,
for another one of his
coronavirus infect-a-thons.
And his big pitch to voters
in Erie
was that he didn't want
to be in Erie.
-Four or five months ago,
when we started
this whole thing --
Because, you know,
before the plague came in,
I had it made.
I wasn't coming to Erie.
I mean, I have to be honest.
There's no way I was coming.
I didn't have to.
I would have called you
and said,
"Hey, Erie, you know,
if you have a chance,
get out and vote."
We had this thing won.
And then we got hit
with the plague,
and I had to go back to work.
"Hello, Erie.
May I please have your vote?"
-Man, you never hear the crowd
at a Trump rally
that silent.
"Yeah! We...suck?
Lock us up?"
Although, in fairness to Trump,
Erie's not my favorite
Great Lake, either.
There's at least one
that's "superior."
[ Glass shatters ]
Feel like that should have
come a tick faster.
That joke was originally
submitted for a "Ziggy" cartoon,
but it was rejected.
Seriously, though, that's quite
the political masterstroke,
Mr. President --
tell the people
whose votes you're courting
you didn't want to be there.
"The last time I left Erie,
I prayed I'd never be back,
that I'd never have to look at
your slack-jawed faces,
and, yet, here I am.
Here I am.
Anyway, vote for me,
you bingo-hall townies,
and try not to choke to death
on a sticker."
By the way,
I don't think he was kidding.
Trump usually goes
for an hour-plus
at these group therapy sessions,
but he told the crowd
he was wrapping up early
because it was cold.
-And, in conclusion --
We'll make this
a little shorter.
You know,
it's like about 40 degrees.
I don't want people --
I don't want to lose anybody.
You got to go vote.
So we're going to go
a little shorter,
because you got to go vote.
-"A little, little shorter."
Alright, first of all,
how can you be cold?
Your trench coat could double
as a business poncho.
But, yeah, I'm sure
you wouldn't want anything
bad to happen to all those
people you invited
to a packed crowd during
a raging pandemic.
Their health and safety is
definitely your top priority.
You know, we've been saying
this, but Trump is doing so much
to help spread the virus,
he should start traveling
with a mascot named COVID Larry.
"Give it up for
COVID Larry, folks.
He'll be shooting T-shirts into
the crowd with his T-shirt gun.
We just have the one shirt,
so if you get it,
put it on, take a picture, and
then hand it to the next guy."
But, in all seriousness,
I'd like to make
this offer to Trump.
We will make the COVID Larry
costume for you
and send it to your campaign
free of charge
if you decide to adopt him
as your official mascot
for the last two weeks
of the campaign.
I mean, what the hell?
Just go for it, man.
You've called COVID a
"blessing from God,"
claimed it made you immune,
that it made you feel powerful,
like Superman.
You've held packed rallies
without masks or distancing,
had a White House
super-spreader event,
made people drive
around with you
while you were
actively infected,
and told your supporters it's
just like the flu.
I mean, you should just
come out as
the pro-COVID candidate already.
Might as well give it a shot.
Nothing else is working.
And if you do that,
our wardrobe department
will send you the costume ASAP.
We'll even size it
so it fits Mike Pence perfectly.
"Uh, Mr. President,
I cannot breathe in here."
"Just put on the suit, Mike.
Do your [bleep] dance, and let's
get the hell out of Erie."
Every day, it seems we get
more horrific news
about the pandemic.
On Tuesday, the CDC said
the pandemic
could cause nearly
300,000 more deaths
than expected in a typical year.
And a study found that
8 million Americans
went into poverty during
the ensuing economic crash.
Or as the president put it
yesterday on "Fox & Friends"...
-Well, we are living with it,
and we're having the vaccines
coming out very soon.
With or without the vaccines,
we're rounding the turn.
-What's the right path for us,
right now,
on opening up our society?
-Well, we have to open up
and we live with it
and we open up our schools.
And I'm the one that got Big Ten
and Pac-12 football back.
You know, I got that back.
That wasn't coming back,
and I got it back.
Hope people realize that.
That was pure and simple me
or whatever.
-You really negate the
"pure and simple"
when you follow it with
"whatever."
"The sky is blue,
pure and simple...or whatever."
Of course, on "Fox & Friends",
it's not even a given
that the sky is blue anymore.
-They went there,
that's where they met,
and it's pretty much been
green skies ever since.
And, by the way,
they also have the --
-Wait. Green skies?
-Oh, should I say blue skies?
-Uh-huh.
Also, is it just me or does it
sound like Trump's heart
is not really in it anymore?
You can almost picture him,
on the other end of the phone,
in The White House packing his
things in a cardboard box,
not really paying attention,
halfheartedly making [bleep] up
because he knows
it's what they want to hear.
"Yeah. Yeah, I saved
college football or whatever.
Hey, Melania,
where's the insta-pot?
'Cause I'm
packing the kitchen, Mel.
Mel, you sold it?
With a yard --
Mel, what about my jambalaya?
Mel, what about Tuesday night
jambalaya night?
Don't slam the door, Mel."
By the way, scientists
have said we wouldn't need
to lock down again if we just
did a few basic things
that public-health officials
are asking for,
things like testing and tracing
on a massive scale,
closing down and subsidizing
the most dangerous businesses,
like indoor bars,
practicing universal
mask wearing, handwashing,
and social distancing.
If we did those things on
a nationwide scale,
we could get back to some
semblance of normalcy,
until vaccines and therapeutics
help us eradicate the disease.
Dr. Fauci has said as much,
repeatedly.
-It occurs because of
the lack of implementation of
simple public-health measures.
It's so frustrating,
because it's not rocket science.
You don't need to lock down.
-It's not rocket science,
unless you're a famous idiot,
like Donald Trump.
Let's remember,
this is the same guy who,
at the start of the pandemic,
went to CDC headquarters
to project
confidence and strength
and literally just held up
a printout
of a coronavirus particle
like a 5th grader
who forgot he had
a science project due.
"The coronavirus particle
was first discovered
by the 18th century German
scientist Johann...Wikipedia."
And, look, I make fun of him
for being dumb,
but I got to give it up.
He is the only person I know
who can get the printer to work.
The reality is,
Trump and the GOP
just do not care about
the pandemic.
They don't care that nearly
300,000 more Americans
have died this year
than otherwise would have.
They don't care that 8 million
people fell into poverty
as a result of
the economic crash.
The one and only thing
they care about
is whining and moaning about
how the media treats them.
It's the only thing that seems
to get them genuinely animated.
They love to complain about not
getting special treatment
on social-media platforms.
My favorite recent example
of this
is a bizarre Instagram post
from Donald Trump Jr.
-Hey, guys.
Hope you're doing well.
Just watching my algorithms
get crushed.
I guess I did something to
piss off the Instagram gods.
So hopefully you're seeing
this stuff anyway.
We'll do what we can.
Talk to you soon.
-I think Instagram might have
shadow-banned you
for not knowing your angles.
Was this shot from the
point of view of the Teddy bear
you tell your problems to?
Also, where are you?
Is that a sleeper car on Amtrak?
And do you have a giant head
or is that a hospital pillow?
Are you going to be Daria
for Halloween?
Seriously, dude,
I never thought I'd say this,
but, you know,
get a journal or something.
Don Jr. is in his 40s,
but he sounds like his best bro
in junior high
just told him he can't have
that extra ticket to Ozzfest.
"Hey, guys.
Hope you're doing well.
Dirk says he's taking his
girlfriend to Ozzfest.
I guess I did something to
piss off the heavy-metal gods.
Talk to you soon."
This gets to
a core truth of Trumpism.
The Trump era has
revealed many things
about what the
modern Conservative movement
actually stands for,
rather than what
they pretend to stand for.
And one thing we've learned
over the last four years
is that the so-called party
of personal responsibility
is actually filled with
whiny, petulant babies
who fill their diapers whenever
you don't give them
exactly what they want.
It's a party of Veruca Salts.
For example, last week,
after NBC inexplicably
did Trump the huge favor
of scheduling a rival town hall
at the exact same time as
Joe Biden's town hall on ABC,
which was scheduled first,
this is how Fox host
Sean Hannity reacted.
-Moments ago, NBC Fake News
did their best to just ambush
President Trump
at tonight's town hall.
He pretty much debated
Savannah Guthrie.
And what we all witnessed
was not journalism.
It was a political debate
with the morning host
of the "Today" show serving as,
well, Joe Biden's surrogate,
and it didn't really work out
well for her.
-It didn't work out
well for her?
I mean, she's still hosting
the "Today" show.
In two weeks, Trump's
going to have a hard time
getting booked on "Maury."
"Can you at least
book me on your
'I had sex with a porn star
during Shark Week' show?
I think I'd be a good guest.
Maury?"
The big news that
came out of the town hall
was the president refusing to
disavow a conspiracy theory
he re-tweeted that
Barack Obama and Joe Biden
had the members of the
Osama bin Laden raid murdered
after they killed
a bin Laden body double
and not the actual bin Laden,
who, according to this theory,
is still alive.
Trump isn't qualified
to be president,
but he should definitely have
a 3:00 a.m. call-in show
on public-access television.
"Tonight's topic is
'Jurassic Park:
A real place being covered up by
aliens working for the CIA?'
Can we put the number
up on the screen?
We can't?
Oh, because Kevin's
not here today?
Okay. I forgot.
Well, here's my first guest,
Curtis Sliwa."
Also, even if that
insane theory was true,
you sure that's the message
you want to close out
the election with?
There might be an
out-of-control pandemic
and a once-in-a-century
economic crash,
but don't worry, folks,
the world's most-wanted
terrorist is still alive.
Do you guys remember Joe Biden's
famous line from 2012?
-Osama bin Laden is dead,
and General Motors is alive.
-Well, a GM plant in Ohio
closed after Trump
promised to save auto jobs.
So I guess his new slogan is,
"GM is dead,
and Osama bin Laden is alive."
which, by the way,
was also a rejected "Ziggy."
So, Hannity thought
it was an ambush.
You might be asking,
"In what way exactly was
this town hall
biased against Trump?"
Well, on his radio show Monday,
Sean Hannity
invited on a guest who broke
maybe the biggest story yet
of the 2020 campaign.
I wish that were true, only to
imagine how it went down.
"Okay, I think we're almost
ready to go.
Let's just bring
those stools out.
Wait. That stool is too big.
Bring out the one
for only half a buttock."
It's ridiculous that a chair for
Trump can be too small.
I mean, even when
he has a giant chair,
he only uses 6 inches of it.
It doesn't matter
how big a chair is,
he's going to sit like
he's watching
the season finale of "24."
He's always lurching forward,
like someone just slammed on
the brakes.
When he meets
with world leaders,
he should wear a seat belt.
It's still just shocking to me
the degree to which grown adults
on the right whine and moan
about not getting special
treatment.
Yesterday, for example,
Trump threatened to release
footage from an interview
he agreed to do
with "60 Minutes"
correspondent Lesley Stahl,
after angrily storming out.
-Multiple sources telling CNN
now that President Trump
abruptly ended a solo interview
with CBS's "60 Minutes" today.
And the president did not
return to the room
for a joint interview with
Vice President Mike Pence.
President Trump sat down with
CBS News' Lesley Stahl
for 45 minutes
before getting up and leaving
and telling CBS that he thought
they had enough material.
-He also tweeted a 6-second
video clip of Stahl
not wearing a mask while
talking with producers
at The White House.
The president later tweeted, "I
am pleased to inform you that,
for the sake of
accuracy in reporting,
I am considering posting
my interview
with Lesley Stahl of
'60 Minutes' prior to airtime.
This will be done
so that everyone
can get a glimpse of what
a fake and biased interview
is all about."
-Well, it sounds like
it went great.
But it was at The White House,
so if the chair
didn't have full-buttock
coverage, that's on you.
I'd love to see the
Trump version of this interview.
I'm guessing when
he releases the footage,
it will look
something like this.
-People are saying
you have so much money
and you are going to win.
-Oh, so, your big gotcha moment
is you caught Lesley Stahl
not wearing a mask for what?
Six seconds?
This will shock you,
but we have blockbuster footage
of you not wearing a mask
at basically every public event
you've ever done.
Why does Trump think
this argument is a winner?
Lesley Stahl
wasn't wearing a mask
for 6 seconds
after an interview.
Meanwhile, the day before he
tested positive for COVID,
Trump was tossing hats
into a packed crowd
like the Phoenix Suns Gorilla.
Hundreds of Americans
are dying every day,
and the country is in the midst
of its third coronavirus wave,
which is already nearing
new records
and which experts predict
could be the worst yet,
and amid all that,
The White House
has decided to spend its time
attacking a "60 Minutes"
correspondent,
even going so far as
to spend time
reviewing footage
of the interview,
searching for ways, I guess,
to make her look bad?
-He didn't walk out.
I mean,
the characterization of that --
He spent over 45 minutes
with Lesley Stahl.
I've looked at
every single minute
of the interview and then some.
-That's what you
were spending your time on?
You're The White House
chief of staff,
not an intern for TV Guide.
There's a raging,
out-of-control pandemic,
and The White House
chief of staff
is poring over tape of a
"60 Minutes" interview
like the Jets' defensive
coordinator after a blowout.
"Okay, everybody.
Do you guys see
what happened here?
We forgot. We forgot to what?
We forgot -- Tackle.
Forgot to tackle.
And what was --
What was he holding?
The person we forgot to tackle.
Do you remember? No?
It wasn't a pointy brown egg.
Anybody? It was the football.
Okay, guys.
Love to not go through this
every week."
Trump and his toadies can whine
about the media all they want.
It doesn't change the
basic story of the campaign.
Nearly 300,000 more Americans
have died this year
than otherwise would have,
and 8 million
have gone into poverty,
and it could have been
prevented.
Remember that when
Trump comes to your town,
tells you he doesn't
want to be there, and says...
-May I please have your vote?
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe, wash your hands,
wear a mask.
We love you.